hey Disneyland Paris right what are you
up to this summer that was rhetorical
you're coming to help me and my friends
the Avengers now we're saving the world
we're looking for top-notch new recruits
with great communication skills a
previous field experience always plus of
course there will be masterclass
training so if you have what it takes
join us hey everybody so we got a Pro
Mode that shows us a much better look at
Iron Man's new armor this is really
really close to what it's actually gonna
look like during the movie it's just a
disneyland promo for all the infinity
war stuff that they're going to be doing
obviously they cut these without some of
the actors so like that's why they have
them facing away from the camera because
the actor playing Thor here is not Thor
and he has long hair because they don't
want to spoil the stuff that's going on
during Ragnarok and infinity war but we
got to talk about the new set picks from
Avengers 4 because there's a lot of
stuff going on people are thinking that
there might be some time-travel involved
with the time gem there's an alternate
theory that I also want to present so
two big theories one time-travel with
the actual time stone legit time-travel
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
second theory some technology left from
Captain America Civil War that Iron Man
was working on that he might bring back
during Avengers 4 so if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I'm also
doing an Infinity Gauntlet giveaway that
I'll explain at the end of the video too
so we'll do the time-travel theory first
then I'll explain the second theory but
the reason why everybody's freaking out
about this is because they've recently
saw pictures of Captain America wearing
his original suit from the first
Avengers film and it's just Iron Man
Captain America Ant Man and Hulk in this
scene on the street in what looks like
this big battle so before you draw any
conclusions just note that Captain
America shield does not have the claw
marks on it from black panther during
civil war and if you're wondering why
some of them have dots on them that's
what Iron Man looks like when he's
walking around on set because his Iron
Man suit is largely done in the computer
usually you just see Robert Downey jr.
walking around set doing his lines and
then later they'll add the Iron Man suit
in post-production there were a couple
of pictures from months and months ago
when they first started filming Avengers
4 that also show scenes that look
they're from the first Avengers film
Thor has his old costume on he has both
of his eyes he has his long blond hair
Loki has the muzzle on him so they're
all these shield guards it looks like
they're getting ready for this scene
here where they all say goodbye and part
ways Thor and Loki go back to Asgard
with the space gem but here's the thing
you see them standing around to this
scene all laughing it looks like
somebody made Chris Evans break like
he's not actually supposed to be
laughing in whatever is happening during
this scene but what's different about
this from the original Battle of New
York ant-man was not there he's wearing
his new version of the costume from
present-day that he gets during infinity
war an Iron Man is wearing different
clothing - if you remember he was
wearing that t-shirt during the first
Avengers film underneath his Iron Man
armor so this might be Captain America
circa 2012 from that first Avengers film
an Iron Man and ant-man travel back into
the past Hulk is a little too hard to
tell because he's gonna be 100% CG so
they'll make him look like whatever they
want to make him look like I think that
no matter what the way that he looked
during Thor Ragnarok is gonna be really
close to what he looks like during
infinity war if you remember this is
what he looked like during the first
Avengers film this is what he looked
like during Ragnarok
so because CG has gotten a little bit
better they made his face more
expressive so that's why he looks
different in the newer films so this
raises more questions than it answers
like why would only a couple of the
Avengers go back in time people have all
kinds of theories about these devices on
their wrists here but the key difference
between the characters here is that
ant-man looks like he has this special
device already built into his gauntlet
this is what the gauntlet looks like
during Civil War this is what it looks
like during Avengers 4 so it might be
Pym tech that allows them to either use
the infinity gems or exist back in the
past just help them withstand the
pressures of using the Infinity stones I
know you can't see it here but when
Chris Evans is laughing it looks like he
does not have one of those little
devices on his wrist but if you go to
this picture it does seem like he has
one so there are just a number of things
that they could be going back to the
original battle of New York to get they
could be going back to get the space gem
they could be going back to change time
so that something goes down differently
in the future
like maybe they actually lose two
a nose and this event comes to pass but
the surviving Avengers find a way to go
back in time and change things like oh
we're gonna die unless we do something
differently or if they're making such a
big deal about these Captain America
scenes they could be going back into the
past to get a version of Captain America
like he might be one of the deaths
during infinity war because bearded
Captain America looks so different from
this version of Chris Evans in Avengers
4 so they might be two completely
different versions of the character so
that you can have Chris Evans in
Avengers 4 he can finish his contract
out because he does have that movie on
his contracts so even if he dies during
infinity war during this big outriders
invasion
you still need to include him in
Avengers 4 in some way in the only way
to do that is time-travel or a flashback
so just remember that you have some of
the current versions of the Avengers in
their new infinity war costumes in the
Battle of New York during 2012
interacting with old versions of the
Avengers for some reason and there's
also what looks like two different
versions of Tony Stark in these scenes
here where they're getting ready to take
Loki back to Asgard you see him with
Point Break Thor here wearing the
original version of his t-shirt from the
first Avengers film then you see another
version of him in the shield gear here -
but here's the other big difference - is
that during infinity war you saw him
with Pepper Potts and those behind the
scenes picks he's wearing this version
of the costume you can clearly see the
arc reactor in the middle of his chest
that's the brand new version of the
costume so the jacket that he's wearing
here is just a little bit different
there's no arc reactor but he has a
bunch of dots on him so it might just be
them adding that in post-production much
much later so moving into the second big
theory and I actually think that this is
probably more likely
there's also a set Pig with this
hippocampus device that Iron Man was
using during Captain America Civil War
remember the scene where he was trying
to remember his parents like you saw the
young version of him it was all weird
because the CG wasn't totally perfect
going to miss us because this is the
last time we're all going to be together
you know what's about to happen
say something if you don't you'll regret
it I love you Dan and I know you did the
best you could
that's how I wish it happen
by nearly augmented retro framing or
barf God I got to work on that acronym
an extremely costly method of hijacking
the hippocampus to clear traumatic
memories so it's a slightly different
version of time travel but that's
basically what he's doing he needs some
information that he can only find in his
memories that he just can't remember
without going back and actually watching
it himself well let me know in the
comments what do you think is actually
going on here do you actually think that
they're legit traveling back in time or
do you think it's just Captain America
Civil War technology and he's travelling
back in his memories and a man is just
here witnessing the simulation with him
big takeaway I think is that Thanos in
present day during infinity war beats
the crap out of all them so whatever
they're doing here it's because of
something that Thanos did in present day
but like I said there's a new round of
that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Marvel related comments on
the video I'll name a winner when I post
new Marvel but congratulations to the
winner from my last video Davey and
Clifton please private message me so I
can get your contact details click here
for brand new black panther and click
here for that venom teaser thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you